[Music]
Mary Queen of Scots is slowly hitting
cinemas and the movie beautifully
depicts the life of Queen Elizabeth and
Mary Queen of Scots on screen throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the film as well as some of the
real-life events that happened after the
credits roll there will of course be
heavy spoilers so if you haven't seen
the movie yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to the year is 1561 and we follow
Mary Stuart as she returns to reclaim
the throne in Scotland Mary the only
surviving legitimate child of King James
v was 6 days old when her father died
and she became a queen at the tender age
of 16 she married the King of France and
was widowed at 18 before deciding to
return to Scotland to take back her
birthright stopping this is Queen
Elizabeth who currently rules over the
country in real life Elizabeth was the
daughter of Henry the 8th and Anne
Boleyn and after her mother was beheaded
she spent the majority of her childhood
in the Tower of London
Elizabeth rightly so is protective over
her throne and this throws her into
conflict with Mary the two women both
admire the competitiveness of their
opposition even though they are rivals
and the film is filled with treachery
and manipulation as the two battle it
out for the throne and both the leads
deliver oscar-worthy performances
throughout historical buffs that know
the backstory will be aware that in real
life Queen Elizabeth never married and
throughout her life did not produce any
airs this is beautifully depicted in the
film and Elizabeth gives the reasoning
that she wishes to remain alone as she
will not be beholden to another man just
opposing this Mary sees marriage as a
way to move up the ranks of society and
those who are informed on the subject
know that in real life she ended up
marrying Lord Darnley in the film
unfortunately Elizabeth's paranoia and
jealousy gets the better of her and she
eventually frames Mary and implicates
her in the
plot the Babington plot was a conspiracy
that planned to assassinate Queen
Elizabeth and put Mary Queen of Scots in
her place on the throne
this is because at the time Britain was
warring over what was the correct way to
worship between Protestants and
Catholics and as Elizabeth was the
former and married the latter it held
grand implications Mary has offered the
chance to absolve herself by giving a
public apology but she refuses which
leads to her trial and execution Mary
dies however safe in the knowledge that
her son James the sixth and later the
first would take the throne upon
Elizabeth's death what makes the film so
tragic and endearing is that you really
feel like Elizabeth is slowly driven
insane over the course of it after a
bout of smallpox elizabeth is left
scarred and due to vanity covers herself
with toxic makeup that leads to her
balding prematurely the reason for a
ghostly white appearance is because
during medieval times being white and
pale was seen as a symbol of wealth
whereas being tanned of men that you
spent a lot of time in the Sun most
likely working in the end
Elizabeth loses someone that she could
share a true kinship with due to her
inner demons her core which is mostly
made up of men and do not respect her
leadership and Mary is an empowering
woman that she could have had a
friendship with had she not been driven
mad with jealousy
Elizabeth tragically died alone and
depressed in 1602 at the age of 69 which
back then was the equivalent of two
lifetimes
prior to this several of her friends
died which sent her into a severe
depression that she did not really
recover from upon her death Elizabeth
was praised as a heroine of the
Protestant cause and the ruler of a
Golden Age King James her successor did
not fare as highly and there were two
conspiracies in the first year of his
reign to overthrow him there existed
several plans to oust him with the
Gunpowder Plot being the most famous of
these even today in England we celebrate
this assassination attempt by Guy Fawkes
which showcases just how unpopular James
was at the age of 50 James suffered
increasingly from arthritis gout and
kidney stones you also lost his teeth
and drank heavily this led to him having
a stroke and James died at the age of 58
so what your thought on the Mary Queen
of Scots film did you enjoy and do you
think either actress will win Anika
me award comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of this month's other big
royal movie the favorite which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]